for a little bit of context I just
talked uh yesterday with a guy named Sam
Harris yeah I don't know if you know Sam
but Sam and because I Was preparing for
a conversation with you I talked to him
about empathy versus reason and he lands
heavily on reason yeah empathy is uh
somewhere between useless and erroneous
and leads you astray and is not
effective that reason is the only way uh
forward well let's draw some fine lines
there and the Two Fine Lines I would
draw is uh first what is your definition
of empathy and then secondly
uh how do people actually make up their
minds and I'm and I'm gonna flip it I'm
gonna go with how people make up their
minds you make up your mind based on
what you care about
period
that makes
reason emotion based yeah what do you
care about you start with what you care
about you see some guys swimming out in
off the coast of the ocean and you see a
shark coming up behind him
who are you cheering for
if it's Adolf Hitler out there you're
cheering for the shark might actually
feel bad for the shark because it's
gonna it's gonna taste bad
who do you care about you mean the human
will taste bad yeah you you know he eats
Adolf Hitler you know they're gonna
leave a bad taste in your mouth even if
you're a shark so you're making up your
mind on every circumstance it's based on
what you care about yeah so then what
does that do to reason your reason is
based on what you care about from the
beginning
now then empathy
if you define it as sympathy which it
was never meant to be sympathy ever
you know I uh
etymology I think is the word I keep
getting etymology and entomology mixed
up etymology being right the the where
words came from the origin entomology
being bugs
got it right so
I like etymology where did something
come from also like entomology anyway uh
etymology the orig my understanding from
my research
uh the original definition of empathy
was an interpretation of a German Ward
where people were trying to figure out
what the artist was trying to convey it
was about assessing art
and so it was always about understanding
where somebody was coming from but not
sharing necessarily
the same thing
so then when I was with the FBI and I
first started collaborating with Harvard
Bob manukan wrote a book
Beyond winning second chapters detention
between empathy and assertiveness
still the best chapter on empathy I've
ever read anywhere
and Bob writes in his book Bob was the
head of the program on negotiation he's
also uh agreed to be interviewed for a
documentary uh that about me and my
company
that hasn't been released yet but it
should be released sometime this year
what's the name of the documentary
tactical empathy good name
so Bob's definition of empathy and said
not agreeing
or even liking the other side
don't even gotta like them don't gotta
agree with them just straight
understanding where they're coming from
and articulating it which requires no
agreement whatsoever
that becomes a very powerful tool like
ridiculously powerful and if it if
sympathy or Compassion or agreement are
not included you can be empathic with
anybody I was thinking about this uh
uh when I was getting ready to sit down
talk to you because you use the word
empathy a lot
um potent
I can be empathic with Putin easy it's
easy
I don't agree with where he's coming
from I don't uh agree with his
methodology
early on the Ukraine Russian war
I saw an article that was very
dismissive of Russia
that said Russia is basically Europe's
gas station
and I thought all right
so if you're in charge
and the way you feed your people
is via an industry that the entire world
is trying to quit
the whole world is trying to get out of
fossil fuels that's how you feed your
people if you don't come up with an
answer to that
the people that you've taken the
responsibility for are going to die
alone in the colds in the dark
they're gonna freeze and they're gonna
die
all right so that doesn't mean that I
agree with where it's coming from or any
of his means
but where where's how does this guy see
things in his distorted word
you're never going to get through to
somebody like that in a conversation
unless you can demonstrate to them you
understand where they're coming from
whether or not you agree
early 90s last century I'm a last
century guy I'm an old dude
refer to myself as a last century guy
also a deeply flawed human yeah
so
um
Tara's case New York City
civilian Court terrorism does not have
to be tried in military tribunals that's
a very bad idea it was always bad
the FBI was always against it
I'm getting ready we have Muslims
testifying in open court against a
legitimate Muslim cleric
the guy that was on trial
had the credentials as a legitimate
Muslim cleric the people who were
testifying against them
didn't think he should be advocating
murder of innocent people
we'd sit down with them Arab Muslims
Egyptians mostly
and I would say to them
you believe that there's been a
succession of American governments for
the last 200 years that are anti-islamic
and they'd shake their head and go
yeah
and that be the start of the
conversation that's empathy
you believe this to be the case I never
said I agreed I never said I disagreed
but I showed him that I wasn't afraid of
their beliefs I was so unafraid of them
that I was willing to just State them
and not disagree or contradict because I
I would say that and then I'd shut up
and let him react and I never had to say
here's why you're wrong I never gave my
point of view
every single one of them that testified
that's empathy not agreeing with where
the other side is coming from
I'm not sure how Sam would define it
but common vernacular is its sympathy
and its compassion and that's when it
becomes useless
and there is a gray area maybe you can
comment on it is sometimes a drop of
compassion
helps make that empathy more effective
in the conversation
so you're just saying you believe
X
doesn't quite form a strong of a bond
with the other person
you're imagining it doesn't maybe you're
right yes I'm imagining it doesn't I'm
imagining you need to show
that you're on the same side
that your but you you need to Signal a
little bit about your actual beliefs at
least in that moment even if those that
signaling is a is uh
not as deep as it sounds but at first
you know basically petting the person on
the back and saying we're on the same
side brother you know that's that's what
most people
when they're really learning the concept
that's the basic human reaction yeah and
in application especially in highly
adversarial situations
like
I I need I need a regular guy Muslim but
how's that guy gonna say buy it if I
like you know do it I'm on your side
I've been there I feel you no no no no
no
people get conned by that so much like
if we're on opposite sides of the table
and I try to act like I'm not on the
opposite side of the table that makes me
disingenuous
so
I would rather
be honest my you know my currency is
integrity
and at some point in time if you go like
you know where I'm coming from my answer
is going to be like look
I can agree on maybe where we're going
but if we're talking about you know am I
on your side now as a human being I want
to see you survive and thrive not at my
expense
I think the world is uh full of
opportunity
um optimistic I got more than enough
reason for saying that
is enough for you for both of us
so I got no problem with you getting
yours you know just don't take it out of
my hand and I'm going to be honest about
it about both of those things I'm not
interested in you taking it out of my
hide I think there's plenty here for
both of us now I don't I don't need to
be on your side except in a in a human
sense but I don't do I have to side with
you of the war no or
the Howard Distributing the stock or how
much you get paid or how much you make
off this car
I think people my experience as a Layman
um is that empathy is not got a downside
that you don't you don't need me
to act like I'm on your side for us to
make a great deal